okay guys it's your boy psychobabble
here playing an old world blues and
that's your place what Kanye right here
too okay so I'm here I'm here did you
retrieve the techni what you did no all
I need yes no and if you remember we
blonde out I suppose it could hmm it
does have any let me I have it the
override secret well not it's embedded
in what seems to be recursive the door
and that message is science um okay
let's just get this back and skipper
hair it's great there okay I got again
I get some ice job
we recorded message indicating my desire
to committee
most impact
Wow
yes
fighting over uh do I have anything
that's okay the [ __ ] of that
and it gets up here
that's not now
like I says I'm [ __ ] up let me just
check to see if there's any [ __ ]
like how that yet
is that okay man I have [ __ ] up that's
all i gotta say probably stocked up on
chef beforehand that is this
these [ __ ] things that it
i need like hell there we go it says
that god stop this is a cut stuff that
kinda stuff that we've been waiting for
uh-huh
ok
no and I laid that
yes yes no
oh yes I'll take that I'll take that
anything else delicious hear any
delicious [ __ ]
there's a lot of good [ __ ] here huh
mm-hmm Cole was like outrageously famous
Jesus
hey no it's always like just like [ __ ]
like a thing that I'm kind of knowing i
think doesn't even want me though I'm
gonna feel like taking the [ __ ] [ __ ] now
I gotta go down that whole line of stuff
what does it read me
ok
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] a that that's for sure
it's blue [ __ ] no
when I cigarettes down
oh god cat
oh that's all good
that's why I do it okay have not checked
this out there that's why the noise [ __ ]
but I'm going to do everything I can get
in this next battle jump good show no
I guys gonna be like crazy addictive the
[ __ ] drugs
why there's so many cigarettes on scale
like he comes out
I hate what [ __ ] this is like pointless
okay [ __ ] a
alright let's just go forward
that's safe though well now hey let
anyone checking on that anyone okay
[ __ ] is
okay let's do it this is serious
oh um yo hello there you are there hey
you'll see familias yeah dance first
solo would you get what the [ __ ] how I
had to stop really but do man tell you
what
yo
oh it it it
huh
oh well is it
minions
time to fight like grain there
right now I think I could have talked
the other ship
like at least stuck his head
[ __ ] sleeping
mmm yo hey
yep
it healed
huh
hey Dean what the [ __ ]
that's it
ok what's the cuesta
retrieve your brain
brains out there oh yes well well look
who finally dragged themselves in
out-of-the-way slap ah lovely yeah well
that's a fine how do you I'm not the one
that makes us clamor around technician
bed and have we forgotten who got a shot
in the head I'm up all the glance they
come from what
I'm not going to lie to you look at it
from my perspective here I have peace in
your head I've got doona overrated
biological what oh no plea ah
after the think tank
hi
sunny like a science
what is my status what am I nice
my science is so [ __ ] close
I'll miss you ah the meat
oh [ __ ]
unless of course the bat I'm not
entirely sure what for
I'm even if I believed you and then even
if I wanted to settle myself back in
your skull and go to all the trouble of
reconnecting there
hello energy weapons
right and I suppose now that were
reunited you want to feel your torso up
with those other meaty parts personally
I think your upgrades are quite a bit
better but now that I'm with you the
sinks autodoc can plug them back in no
problem right there off wit
ok
swimming
hey some [ __ ] aid
shutting up
hmm I guess I don't have more talking I
get two batches and I like [ __ ] a
decade
okay autodoc out of back you require
some edition
okay good you require some additional
perhaps there we go to put says jump and
then I fairness the Celtic fans of a
light opera good
ok
Thank deck we cut it what the [ __ ]
little bottom ice returns oh I'll
lobotomize
oh [ __ ] let me just see what else
happens
effective instead
little bottom ice returns oh I recommend
watching your toe now your brain hmm and
what could we possibly have to speak
about with it we can finally leave this
place and we have so many
yes I'm not going to hi yeah
[ __ ]
yeah okay cut them up oh okay all done
i'll have like bucks teddy bear that's
optic line
there anything else important here man
let's get the [ __ ] out of here what I
have to as it had been in the years
before the Great War big mountain ver
big empty became home to one of the
brightest minds of the 23rd century The
Courier watched over the big empty for
years to come caring for it and keeping
its discovery safe until they were
needed to help others which had always
been big mountains purpose hmm past the
laboratories and science it had always
been intended as a place to build the
future of all mankind although truth be
told the Korea had barely explored the
crater in an attempt to rush through and
be done with the whole thing ok perhaps
that was for the best however curiosity
well sometimes rewarded for exhibits
often proves to be equally dangerous the
Forbidden Zone continued to be true to
its name forbidden no more Robo
scorpions were sighted in its canyons
big mountain became even emptier devoid
of dr. Mobius proclamations forecasting
the destruction of anything that dared
possess sentience still it is said he
lived on in the equations inscribed on
the floor and walls of the Forbidden
Zone dome a cobweb tracery of symbols
that told of a thousand brilliant
thoughts now lost to time the sink atop
the dome bustled with the voices of a
small town constantly chirping arguing
and snarling at each other again still
this all happened productively in the
interests of its new owner the sink
Central Intelligence Unit discovered
despite its inversion code it was
comforted by the sense of community the
other personalities gave it the
biological research station obsessed
with seeding everything in sight
requested a transfer to the X 22
botanical garden so that it might in its
own words sends really fertilized
garden smooth come to us I can get
behind that the garden sent back a
polite refusal saying it had prior
commitments with a vault it had helped
infect before the war the book shoot
continued to devour all seditious
materials until it nearly choked on a
paper clip it adamantly maintained it
was a Chinese paper clip and the whole
thing had been an elaborately
orchestrated assassination attempt
whatever the reason it slowed down for a
while carefully appraising each document
and clipboard that came to it ok the
light switches continue to pick up and
flicker this persisted until the day
someone dropped a flashlight in the sink
and the two of them united in their
hatred of the Showboat the scene
continued to ruthlessly scrub any
particulate matter that came near it
eventually it gained access to the
magneto hydraulics plant and nearly
flooded all the big empty in an attempt
to scrub the crater clean bandai old
jefferson eventually discovered a new
sound silence ok and only made him more
filled with the blues and before I got
it was rumored by the other
personalities that he had a brief fling
with the light switches although he
forgot their names once too often and
was soon left in the dark as punishment
autodoc always gentle and methodical get
selling up the courier in all the right
places when the skin split open from
repeated wear and tear the autodoc was
just glad to have purpose again it heard
it's simpler brothers and sisters who
got shipped to the sierra madre bored
out of their skulls in that toxic dead
city in time the autodoc found a way to
deactivate the wise 17 trauma harnesses
releasing the corpses they had held
prisoner for all
200 years as the courier ran through the
x8 facility multiple times the computers
analyzed the test subjects movements
rather than performing a superficial
observation they realized the subject
barely knew what communism was or even
what a high school was this confused
them for a time until the facility
finally realized that its research had
succeeded so it led its cyber dogs out
into the wastes and to help protect
small communities from physical
aggression rather than communist
propaganda the infiltration program and
x13 continue to scan for the subject the
stealth suit prototype long after the
test was over frustrated and unable to
find its lost technology x13 expanded
its network of laser tripwires sensors
and Robo brains out across big mansion
this glittering blue light beam forest
cleanly bisected anything that entered
its depths slicing them into small
segmented parts for easy disposal the
Korea organs intact continued onwards a
little less heavy of step but with all
the organs in the right places as they
should be after all brains can develop a
life of their own when left to their own
thoughts and the courier's brain was
more clever than most the think-tank
basement filled with lobotomize robotica
frames of the doctors now served as a
graveyard the monitors had recorded the
battle in its entirety including the
think tanks final shrill terrified
screams whimpers and pleas for mercy
they broadcast these humiliating last
moments as a warning to anyone
approaching the perimeter that others
smarty pants were not welcome the
courier was the inheritor of the big
empty and there was room for only one
will
in the halls of the think tank dome
there is an expression in the wasteland
old world blues it refers to those so
obsessed with the past they can't see
the present much less the future for
what it is they stare into the what was
eyes like pilot lights guttering and
spent as the realities of their world
continue on around them science is a
long steady progression into the future
what may seem a sudden event often isn't
felt for years even centuries to come in
the times following the second battle of
hoover dam however old world blues took
on a new meaning where once it was
viewed as a form of sadness nostalgia it
became an expression describing the
potential for the future it can be easy
to see science as evil technology
unchecked as the source of all ills all
misfortunes with the courier at the helm
science became a beacon for the future
there was old world blues a new world
hope and hope ruled the day at Big
Mountain we could say more but the
stories in the big empty speak for
themselves now armed with the
transportal ponder the courier would
return to the damn it any time and crack
open the secrets of the big empty one by
one the sink sad vigilant waiting for
its master to return shoes covered in
Mojave dust only one road yet remained
and it was one of the courier had to
walk alone
hmm God got the long summer out they'll
also grow
yeah yeah